bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados más de 10 años de
guerra civil en libia
un conflicto de intereses internos y
externos porque inició este conflicto
porque no se han logrado resolver y cuál
es el panorama hoy en día empecemos con
un poco de historia libia en el
mediterráneo es un país históricamente
deseado por imperios y potencias tras su
independencia en 1951 se descubrió que
el país tenía suculentos yacimientos de
petróleo y las empresas extranjeras se
mudaron allí para explotarlos en 1969
hubo un golpe de estado tras el cual
estaba el general muamar al gadafi quien
instauró un mandato basado en el islam y
el socialismo su gobierno nacionalizó
empresas petrolíferas algo que nos gustó
mucho occidente kadhafi estuvo acusado
de financiar terroristas guerrillas o
estados contrarios a eeuu y por todo
ello washington impuso sanciones a libia
lo que hizo a kaddafi ceder tanto en la
explotación de petróleo como en otros
temas luego washington y trípoli se
unieron durante años para luchar contra
al qaeda y así
unos años de estabilidad para el país
entonces cómo inició esta cruenta guerra
en 2011 estalló la primavera árabe con
demandas de cambio gadafi había
gobernado a base de violencia por
décadas y con esa misma violencia se
levantaron contra el milicias armadas en
todo el país la respuesta de gadafi fue
sangrienta y la otan alegando la
protección a los derechos civiles aunque
muchos expertos apuntan a intereses más
ligados al petróleo inició una ofensiva
militar y ayudó a los rebeldes a tomar
el poder gadafi murió en octubre de 2011
a manos de milicianos se esperaba que
tras su violenta muerte llegaría la paz
a libia pero lo peor acababa de empezar
porque no se ha logrado resolver la
guerra tras la caída de gadafi había
milicias armadas de múltiples ideologías
intereses y religiones repartidas por
todo el país que intentaron llenar el
vacío de poder que dejó el país se
dividió por un lado en el este en tobruk
se atrincheraron los liberales con
milicias que lucharon contra gadafi
agrupadas bajo el mando del general
jalifa haftar captar fue un antiguo
aliado de gadafi quien había roto
relaciones con el dictador y estuvo un
tiempo exiliado en eeuu pero regresó
durante las protestas y desde entonces
se ha ido convirtiendo en uno de los
hombres fuertes del país este bando
fundó el llamado gobierno de tu grupo
por otro lado al oeste en trípoli se
estableció el gobierno de acuerdo
nacional el general liderado por fallece
al zar y reconocido por las naciones
unidas además en medio de la guerra
también se levantaron células del
autodenominado estado islámico filiales
de al qaeda y otros grupos terroristas
así como etnias locales que luchan por
el control del sur del país en 2014 a
estar inició una ofensiva en el este y
sur de libia luego a pesar de los
esfuerzos de internacionales en 2019
after llevó a cabo una sorpresiva
ofensiva para tomar trípoli pero no
logró hacerse con el poder aunque eso sí
actualmente controla la mayor parte del
territorio el conflicto ha sido
alimentado desde el extranjero múltiples
países con intereses concretos han
financiado armamento entrenamiento
militar o enviado mercenarios a los
distintos bandos qatar y turquía apoyan
al gobierno de acuerdo nacional con base
en trípoli ankara incluso ha admitido
públicamente haber enviado armas drones
vehículos y aviones por su parte eeuu
francia rusia egipto arabia saudita y
emiratos árabes unidos apoyan al
gobierno de tobruk del general haftar a
rusia se le acusa de enviar mercenarios
alineados con los intereses de moscú el
grupo vag net aunque moscú la amnistía
internacional acusa tanto al gobierno de
acuerdo nacional apoyado por la onu como
al gobierno de tobruk de todo tipo de
crímenes de guerra
y cuál es la situación ahora la guerra
se ha traducido en cientos de miles de
desplazados masacres asesinatos
sistémicos y violaciones en masa y ha
llevado a libia a convertirse en un
estado fallido en octubre de 2020 se
logró un alto al fuego con el compromiso
de celebrar elecciones presidenciales el
24 de diciembre
comicios que se tambalean sin una ley
electoral clara entre decenas de
candidatos está la del general jalifa
haftar sobre que empiezan un sinfín de
acusaciones de violaciones a los
derechos humanos también se postuló saif
al islam hijo de muamar al gadafi
buscado por la corte penal internacional
por crímenes contra la humanidad aunque
su candidatura fue anulada diferentes
ong acusan a la onu de hacer la vista
gorda de los crímenes cometidos por
bando y bando con tal de llevar a cabo
las elecciones y expertos advierten que
los comicios a falta de estabilidad
política podrían degenerar en otro
episodio de guerra por su parte naciones
unidas'
que de no haber un proceso electoral los
conflictos se avivarán con bandos
rivales intereses internacionales y
mercenarios y armas por doquier el
conflicto ha escalado a un nivel en el
que solamente el diálogo y la voluntad
política podrán sacar a la población
libia del infierno que vive hace diez
años si le sirvió el vídeo para entender
la crisis en libia los esperamos en otro
episodio de en 5 minutos aquí en france